pourquoi il faut fermer les abattoirs
moi je réponds oui et valérie non les
abattoirs dans l'évent vérité tu vas
être comblé mais j'assume j'ai enlevé
arrête tu as suivi à rennes on arrête
d'être démago comme ça à l'arrivée
valérie art est insupportable cinq
centrales je trouve pas aujourd'hui
travaillent là bas aussi on peut être
sûr excuses moi jle mais la chute est
insupportable en s'imposant très
choquant qu'il dit si tu poses ton cul
sur la chaise était content de
travailler pense à dia plein de gens qui
travaillent et qui ont besoin de
travailler arrête de dire des conneries
bon bah non mais c'est vrai t'as pelage
il arrête ça m'énerve ça me rend fou ça
le mec il est tranquille ici tu es au
chaud tu poses ton pulsions de table et
un salaire tous les mois tu vas mettre
des milliers de gens au chômage arrête
un peu près la moitié de ces gens là
cyril ils sont limite en dépression ça
aussi
vivant plein doute jarrett jack
arrêter les conneries et même lignée de
restaurateurs qui cherchent des serveurs
isabelle soit et autre chose il le
ferait désolé pour la plus faste où vous
dites la moitié sans dépression donc
c'est à dire que la moitié et ceux qui
sont en effet six avaient le choix s'ils
avaient le choix de faire autre chose il
l'aurait fait donc ils n'ont pas le
choix et quand gilles verdez tu dis il
faut fermer tous les abattoirs
excuse-moi jun ce qu'on peut être
démagogique et puis merde excuse moi tu
te rends pas compte qu'il ya des mecs
qui vont se retrouver au chômage du jour
au lendemain alors arrête tes conneries
arrête un peu de vouloir d'être démago
surtout pense un peu avant de s'engager
pour des contrôles bah oui on voit tout
ce qui a dévalé réunissant on est tout à
fait d'accord et l'association l214 il
faut un travail magnifique je voulais
pour ça parce qu'il manque des choses et
il montre qu' il ya des ya des ja il ya
parfois il ya des choses qui vont pas et
ça c'est important de monde et c'est
pour ça qu'on le montre ce soir on va on
aurait pu ne pas faire le sujet mais
quand tu lis il faut fermer les
abattoirs d'une connerie van zyl je peux
finir oui bah oui parce que en fait
monsieur de normandie le ministre de
l'agriculture il a fait des tas de
planches je les ai tous regarder les
plans abattoirs ça ne fonctionne pas
depuis 2020 il ya six abattoirs qui ont
été fermés quatre ont pu rouvrir rien ne
change donc si vous voulez continuer
cyril avoir des images comme çà et là ne
faisons rien n'est arrêté
mais tu penses o'toole à tous les autres
mois toucherait tu vas faire quoi après
venir sur le plateau et tu fais de la ba
oui bah ils ont éloigné est toujours là
tu es toujours en train de défendre ceux
qui sont sur deux passions l'art alain
vernon les animaux c'est
qu'on veut tous défendre les animaux il
faut défendre aussi les humains mais
plusieurs traders des quadrilles un
deuxième arrêt de fermer les choses
étape ya plein de gens qui sont au
chômage ya plein de gens qui travaillent
tu te rends compte ou pas d'astuce tri
d'après les images racontent que c'est
l'industrie de la viande au championnat
où ils n'ont pas baissé
les centaines de milliers de gens au
chômage arrête un peu mais je dis des
conneries excuse moi ça me rend fou moi
c'est les mecs comme toi excuse moi ça
me rend fou donc vous êtes en dehors de
la société excuse moi j'irai de poser à
côté de la plaque à chaque fois tu veux
faire plaisir à tout le monde se faire
plaisir aux animaux tu veux faire
plaisir à tout le monde n'est pas de
connerie il faut il ya ya ya ya d'iliad
eyadema l'avenir dira d'eyadema ya dès
qu'il ya des malveillances et des choses
qui sont mal faites et alors il faut
essayer de les régler mais tu vas pas
mettre des millions chf et tu apparais
que l'industrie de la viande tous les
bouchers boîte au chômage aussi on va
fermer toutes les boucheries les ier
dampmart est à peu près cela bord pense
d'abord un petit peu aux rumeurs que les
sims à la violence mais gérable une
fatigue d'abord macho que vous faites un
travail incroyable sur c'est pour ça
qu'on est au dessus de soi c'est bien
pour ça et justement ça dénonce les
abattoirs low cost absolument cruel
indigne a exhorté leurs locaux c'est pas
low cost et me sall dit c'est pas les
soirs du groupe bigard donc le groupe
bigard ccam le premier groupe 6 pts de
viande
le groupe
s'y mettre tous les gens du groupe
bigard au chômage on peut pas dire on va
pas le côté me car demain je suis désolé
arrêter un peu cher parce que les gens
veulent manger de la viande pas cher et
donc les gens achètent de la viande pas
cher parce qu'ils ont des problèmes
aussi pouvoir d'achat ils veulent
pouvoir aimer sa forme à huy et on a
besoin on a besoin d'avoir moi j'ai deux
minutes après tout avec un ayant thomas
j'adore ça et je veux pas être vegan
parce que je veux pas je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils m'ont dit oh my tho mode tout
soit bien comment on fait justement
comment comment fait vous monsieur vous
pensé pour réguler sa et pour qu'ils
abattoirs ben clean le plus clean
possible et le plus respectueux de la
maladie qu'on trouve déjà il ya des
choses jamais revenir sur le débat sur
le sol et êtres humains moi j'ai
beaucoup de compassion pour les employés
des abattoirs important de le dire voilà
beaucoup travaillé avec eux il ya
énormément d'énergie non bien sûr il ya
beau y ait beaucoup d'immigrés beaucoup
de personnes aussi qui sont en
souffrance c'est un travail qui est
répétitif de la circulaire d'exemplaires
musculaire oui on travaille d'antan avec
du son des odeurs de pure joie des
masques je vous dire comment mais il
disait tout évolue désormais disparaît
donc s'ils font ça c'est qu'ils doivent
pas faire autre chose bien sûr qu'ils
ont besoin de bien sûr mais la sauce est
révolu donc ça prend du temps ça pas se
faire en un jour mais peut être sur
plusieurs générations mais il ya des
métiers disparaissent d'autres qui
apparaissent donc sur du long terme
c'est totalement faisable donc la
question n'est pas de savoir si si si on
va perdre des emplois c'est d'abord de
dire est-ce que c'est légitime encore en
france d'avoir ce genre d'image en fait
moi j'ai parlé aux vétérans de
l'abattoir elle m'a dit clairement peu
importe la méthode d'abattage les
animaux souffrent sur l'abattage
traditionnel l'abattage rituel est à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de
solution miracle en fait en france dont
tu te crois bien que le 5 millions
d'animaux chaque jour donc si les
français veulent continuer à consommer
autant de viande on pourra y aura
toujours de la souffrance elles auraient
toujours il faut réduire la consommation
de riz de viande de la vessie d'après
vous dans les apps dans les abattoirs on
descend de la cadence et donc on soit un
peu plus exactement
si on veut respecter l'être humain à
l'animal la moindre des choses commencer
par réduire tout à fait part
d'informations alors mois idéalement
personnellement je préférerais qu'on
arrête mais si on peut déjà commencer
par réduire
améliorer les conditions mais parce
qu'il ya des gens qui bossent de la
réunion qui est pas trop j'ai
effectivement tout le monde voudrait
membres et d'avions qui est parfaitement
évident les précaires mais c'est la
levée le kilo de boeuf qui doit toucher
pas il est deux fois on trouve un
plaisir que de marcher donc c'est un
vrai problème effectivement moi j'ai
tout le monde est content et seront des
animaux on va pas son vis à vis là on
veut pas traîner me souvenais julien
mosca se passer si vous fermez des
abattoirs comme vous dis bah oui il vers
des cela elle parce que la mauvaise idée
excuse moi je vous adore plus agile vous
ne savez en dehors de ça mais ça c'est
la plus minime et on espère bien pas du
tout il va vendre aux étrangers et on
est à l'étranger à l'étranger n'ont pas
fermé avez vous douté de la place en
fait question voulez vous qu en fait je
vous dis et je trouve que l 214 ils font
un super travail justement pour montrer
ça ça il faut le montrer au gouvernement
qu'il essaie de faire des choses qu'ils
essaient d'améliorer tout ça mais là
dire fermer des abattoirs fermer les
sociétés et les délais parce que
derrière c'est qu'on va fermer les
boucheries qui va fermer des lits
n'importe quoi mais oui mais c'est
n'importe quoi et bien vous serez quoi
vous savez quoi on verra quand vous
aurez des millions de personnes au
chômage on verra ce que vous ferez vous
allez dire aussi c'est pas bien mais on
a des milliers de mettre au chômage